joining me now stephen miller founder of
america first legal former senior
advisor to president trump and molly
hemingway senior editor at the
federalist and fox news contributor
molly if they really thought their
policies were so popular
would they be running
to the abortion issue so
enthusiastically well first off i don't
think abortion is as good of an issue
for them as they seem to think their
view is actually incredibly extreme
every single democrat across the country
believes that that abortion should be
allowed through all nine months of
pregnancy for any reason so if you want
to kill an unborn child because she's a
girl they think that that should be fine
the republican position is simply that
states should be able to make those
decisions themselves so i'm not sure if
as people think about these issues
whether that argument will even work but
obviously the real issues are the ones
people you know that people really care
about in their day-to-day this is the
economy inflation the border which is
completely open you know in the south
crime which is rampant in so many cities
and what's happening in our schools and
democrats don't have anything to say
about them can you believe the dc story
these kids aren't going to be able to go
virtual
but that tells you everything you need
these people are frauds i'm going to say
it america these people are frauds they
don't care about your children they
don't care about you it's all about the
real dictatorship of ideas
i'm sorry i'm so upset about the school
issues i can't i can't even believe it
steven here's what biden said at a
fundraiser that occurred before his
30-minute rant tonight and by the way it
screwed up traffic all over dc he said
we're seeing now that either the
beginning or the death knell of an
extreme maga agenda it's not just trump
it's almost semi-fascism
he said
i think freud called that projection if
you want to know what the fascist party
is in america it's joe biden's
democratic party what is fascism raiding
the home of your political opponent for
purely political reasons
shutting down people's lives and
businesses kicking people out of school
because they won't get your vaccine
leaving people at the mercy of violent
criminals while weaponizing justice
against your political opposition those
are fascist actions you and elsa's
fascist for giving student loan debt
illegally going around congress with no
constitutional authority instead of
asking for a law all of those activities
are fascist and republicans should point
out that we are now the freedom party
they are now the party of tyranny and
repression and control from air
conditioning to now gas-powered vehicles
i mean we've heard it all molly here was
another stellar moment from biden's rant
fest this evening
and it's not hyperbole the very survival
of our planet is on the ballot and it's
not hyperbole now you need to vote to
literally save democracy again
kids get off my lawn molly your reaction
that is
the definition of hyperbole but these
this type of rhetoric really is
frustrating because when you think about
the definition of fascism this is the
joining of corporations with the party
you know just tonight we saw that mark
zuckerberg says that the fbi had
facebook censored the hunter biden
laptop and information that's what so
many technology companies are doing in
in
congress with these with the party that
is fascism that is something that
everyone should hate whether they're
republican or democrat and it's
happening and it's really affecting our
freedom google announced yesterday
speaking of molly's point google
announced yesterday that was going to
undertake a disinformation
scrub in europe so
everything that's happening in europe
they want to bring here right so that's
ultimately coming here a disinformation
scrub and worse europe step one the
really one is the chinese system here in
america that's what they really admire
especially all of these
credit score tonight it's even very
little it's very low molly i don't even
think you raid on the side of the
credits
but it's can you imagine getting
democracy lectures from the lockdown
party democracy lectures from the people
that stole the childhood of millions of
students and wouldn't even let them go
to school and is still not letting them
go to school democracy lectures from a
president who is illegally violating the
law every day by keeping our border open
despite decades of laws passed by
congress saying that the border has to
be secure and illegal immigrants
deported this is a man who has contempt
for democracy contempt for congress and
contempt for the american people molly
41.5 percent is the 538 approval for
biden
they're actually bragging about that
that's a that's a brag for them
i've even heard people say that things
are going better for biden yeah it's
like the momentum jomentum in fact his
numbers are even lower than they were
last year and the policies are so deeply
unpopular that that's why the
fundamentals of this election will
remain the same and the out party which
is the republican party should stand to
gain they do need to articulate what
they want to do i agree molly and
they're telling me i have to go but i
have to ask you because you wrote a
great column about this the leadership
of the republican party griping about
the candidates i'm done with that they
got to stop that these people are
courageous to be in this ring right now
first time candidates blake masters
herschel walker oz i mean i wasn't for
oz but you've got to have oz win and you
had you had the point that people say
that they don't like the direction of
the country having outsider candidates
is a response to that and and regardless
if you know if the leadership can't
support these candidates they should
just be quiet the life of the
republicans at stake right just get out
of the way if you can't support just the
planet i'd always say it's not hyperbole
but if you don't vote democrat we're all
burning up in three months all right
stephen and molly great to see you both
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else